we cross source
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my Witcher Netflix top 10
WTF video for the first half of the
season it dropped this weekend but
because there's so much Star Wars stuff
happening I think a lot of people have
only made it through the first part of
the episodes but if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything I will be doing more videos
for this series through the next week
just because it's the holiday so
everyone's slowly catching up with
everything
obviously careful for spoilers from the
first half of the episodes in The
Witcher Netflix it's pretty accurate to
the books so if you've read any of the
books or you played the games and they
deal with some of the back story during
the games you have a pretty good idea
for what's going on during this I'll
explain what's going on with the
timeline too because one of the big
changes they made is the way they tell
the story so top 10 WTF in Easter eggs
starting with number 10 the timeline
there's a very important reason why it
seems like each of the three main
characters Geralt ciri and yennefer have
competing timelines so a lot of what you
see happening with ciri at the beginning
of the story is happening way later in
geralt and yennefer timeline because
they're very long-lived because of their
mutations that they undergo or
technically it's enchantments
in-universe casts all of the tv-show is
adapting the books not the video games
the video games story is a sequel to the
book story so think of this more as a
game of Thrones situation where they're
adapting the novels the story of the
first season is largely based on the two
first short story books the last wish in
sort of destiny so the weird thing that
happened in the United States is they
didn't publish those books till after
the other books it was a bit of a Star
Wars situation let's start with episode
4 then we'll do all the backstory in the
prequels a little bit later all the
monsters that he fights in the first
couple of episodes through the main
season are right out of the books for
example one of the names of the early
short stories is the lesser evil
quote-unquote that's the story of how
Geralt became the butcher of lavich and
so during episode one when they do that
story that's why the characters like
Strega boar and ren free keep repeating
that line of dialogue kill ren free
because it's the lesser
evil no-kill stray Gabor because that's
the lesser evil so all of geralt and
yennefer story in the first few episodes
starts a long time ago in the past then
their timelines slowly catch up with
series timeline so in the first episode
you watch sintra gets sacked by
nilfgaard they have that giant battle in
the field that's right out of the books
serious escapes running off that's a
little bit of a change from the books in
the book she actually ran off to escape
and arranged marriage but sintra later
in the timeline after that still gets
sacked by nilfgaard so they're combining
a bunch of things but because Geralt
timeline has been catching up with Syria
this whole time you get the reveal about
midway through the season the Geralt was
here while sintra was getting sacked he
was just stuck in the dungeon the whole
time but that's also another big change
from the books Geralt finds out about
what happened to central ater he meets
ciri way later in the books the main
reason why they did the timelines this
way is because both ciri and yennefer
don't really appear in those initial
short stories that they're adapting till
the very very end the last wish is the
name of the short story with the gin
where Gale meets yennefer for the first
time and that's much later in the first
few books and the writers wanted to have
you follow all three main characters
starting in episode 1 so the only way to
do that was to mess with the timeline a
little bit but the way they tell the
story but number 9 WTF Geralt becomes
the butcher of blacken like I said this
is basically the entire story of the
first episode based on the short story
the lesser evil quote-unquote as they
repeated the line of dialogue during the
episode but it's the same basic plot as
it is in the books
Strega Bor is a total [ __ ] mage
working for the brotherhood of sorcerers
and he learns about the curse of the
Black Sun a prophecy that says a bunch
of girls born under an eclipse will
become possessed and destroy the world
so a long time ago he does what any
crazy sorcerer would do he goes around
trying to kill all the women that were
born under the Eclipse he also spends a
lot of his free time vivisecting the
bodies he really likes poking around in
people's innards
so he's way worse in the books than what
the show made him out to be Ren free
just happened to be a princess born
under an eclipse so her mother the Queen
just gave her over to Strega Bor to get
rid of oh wow she's gonna destroy the
world well we got to get rid of her the
backstory that she tells to Geralt
during the episode is pretty accurate to
the books she escaped her captor then
spent the
to her life plotting her revenge against
her mother and against Strega bore the
reason Geralt is forced to kill her even
though he hates Strega boar finds him
deplorable is that Ren free claims she's
gonna slaughter all the innocent town's
folk here in the street until stray
Gabor comes out of his tower which he's
definitely not going to do so Geralt has
to stop her to save all these innocent
lives she's kind of turned into a
monster
in the episode is meant to show you that
sometimes people are worse than the
actual monsters the girls usually hired
to fight that's why they juxtaposed it
by having him fight the key Kimora at
the top of the episode like he's
fighting a monster but that monster
might seem bad not quite as bad as the
human monster that Strega boar and Ren
free are one of the tag lines of the
show is also sometimes the worst
monsters are the ones we create as in
Strega boar created the monster that Ren
free turned into through his actions
somatically that will also play through
the rest of the major storylines of the
series like sintra what's going on with
no scars the reason why they sacked
sintra what's going on with Emperor Amir
who you really only learn about halfway
through the season it'll become more
clear once we get into season two there
are a couple things that they don't
reveal during season 1 so I'll try to
step around that because it does get
kind of spoilery so I'll be sure not to
include that stuff in this video number
8 WTF like I said this happens much
later in the books but series storyline
starts out way later in the timeline
probably the biggest change they make to
this though is that Geralt is here fer
to this stuff while it happens where he
is not in the books there are two major
reasons why nilfgaard is attacking
sintra one the main reason is because
emperor emir of nilfgaard in the north
is trying to unify the entire continent
so he's doing this with his army all
over the place it just happens that
right now he's at sintra number two
though secondary reason is that he's
coming for ciri there's a lot of
potentially super spoilery stuff early
on with serious storyline so I will skip
that part and explain who Emperor Amir
is at least right now maybe I'll cover
that later but he wants ciri because of
her special bloodline in her power but
while this is all going on you get a
quick tutorial for her grandmother a
queen kalantay the lioness of sintra
she's sort of a combination a Brienne of
Tarth and Cersei Lannister she wins that
throw
yourself off the battlements at the end
of the episode to prevent being taken
captive you don't really get the
backstory on how we came to this moment
though in this big battle until a
flashback episode is part of Jerrold
storyline in the later episode number 7
though meet ciri and her special special
blood and powers but she has what he
would call the elder blood in her veins
passed down through her mother's side of
the family her great-grandmother the
Queen's mother had the power but it
skipped her grandmother Queen kalantay
and manifested in both series mother
pavetta and now ciri herself quick
tutorial on what the elder blood is and
what it means
so the elder blood is a genetic program
initiated by elven mages a long time ago
for the purposes of creating an
extraordinarily gifted child whose power
would exceed their own and they spent a
lot of time in the first half of the
season explaining that elven mages are
the most powerful
they're the original magic users of the
continent there's an elven prophecy
about a child of the elder blood one day
saving the elves from Total Annihilation
a long time ago in this genetic line one
of the elves made it with a human and
created the line that ciri comes from so
that's how she wound up with the elder
blood so throughout the series a lot of
competing interests both elven both
human evil people good people all want
to get their hands on ciri to use her
power really good example of how
powerful she is yennefer is one-quarter
elf by blood that by itself makes her
way more powerful than a regular human
mage ciri because of her elder blood is
like God Tyr powerful but very few
people actually understand how her power
works one of those people that you meet
later in the series
vil Giffords understands he's a mage he
doesn't start out being super evil but
he's one of the main antagonists of the
book series along with Emperor Amir but
if we're making videogame jokes here
ciri is more of like the side fetch
quest for Emperor Amir as part of his
larger campaign to unify the continent
with all these wars number six
Jennifer's origin story you don't really
get yennefer backstory until episode 2
but the big change they made from the
books is that they give you Yan AFER's
backstory in the books she just shows up
here in the last wish storyline during
the Djinn Adventure as a full-blown
sorceress like hello how's it going
my name's Jennifer for the most part all
the backstory that they give you for
yennefer is accurate to the books she
was abused by her father she was born as
a hunchback she's taken in by the
brotherhood of sorcerers to train when
she passes the necessary tests she
undergoes her enchantments to get rid of
her deformities but at the cost of her
ability to reproduce but eventually what
happens is because neither she nor
Geralt can sire children because of
Geralt mutations as a Witcher and
because of her enchantments is that
eventually they emotionally adopt ciri
as their daughter so she becomes
something of a mother figure to Siri
Geralt becomes something of a father
figure eventually number five though yes
Kieran Geralt so you meet yes Kier in
Episode two just like you meet yennefer
his character and personality the
version you see on the TV show is pretty
accurate to the books he meets Geralt on
the road starts following him around and
slowly wears him down until eventually
Geralt starts to think of him as a
friend
most of the time he just annoys people
though the TV show version is way less
hot for yennefer than the book version
speaking of which number four WTF Geralt
saves yennefer his life by using the
last wish so that's why the story in the
books that they're pulling from here is
called the last wish because he uses
that third and final wish to save her
from the Djinn and as part of that wish
that he doesn't speak out loud on the
show is to bind their destinies together
forever during the episode he doesn't
speak the wish out loud the Djinn just
leaves
Jennifer's body and she's saved flies
away but the wish was that their fates
forever be intertwined
that's why later in the timeline when
they go in the dragon monster hunt she
shows up and is like how come there are
so few witcher's left in the world but
all of a sudden I keep running into you
everywhere I go it's part of the magic
of the wish that keeps bringing them
back together but number three Geralt
versus the Striga this is also right out
of the books but the change that the TV
show makes is that in the episode they
cross cut the string as transformation
back into the princess with Jennifer's
transformation for dramatic effect if
you played any of the Witcher video
games you probably recognize that this
adventure to the Striga is literally the
opening cutscene of the very first
Witcher game the backstory that they
give you in the episode is pretty
accurate to the books king foltest
and his sister go full Jaime and Cersei
Lannister they have a baby but there
Union was cursed as a result his sister
died while pregnant with the child
before she gave birth she was buried in
a tomb but because of the curse the
child in her womb slowly transformed
into the Strega and then started
terrorizing temeria until Geralt broke
the curse by keeping her from returning
to her tomb till sunrise but something
that might not be clear from the episode
is that the child had been a stricka--
for more than a decade so she's never
known life as a human the story and
somewhat hopefully for her as king
foltest agrees to race her properly and
care for her but it's gonna take years
and years for her to recover from the
mental trauma of being a monster that
ate peoples hearts and livers for more
than a decade number two WTF the story
of Dooney pavetta and series origin
story they don't do the duniya pavetta
flashback till around the middle of the
season but you start to learn why sintra
eventually fell and where ciri came from
and how she became gerelds child of
surprise but you meet Ceres mother
pavetta daughter of Queen Kelantan II
the lioness of sintra who's just loving
life without a husband doing what she
wants being a badass but needs more
troops for her wards so she's gonna
marry off her daughter pavetta to
whichever neighboring kingdom can give
her more forces pavetta is secretly in
love with a man named unni who claims
claims quote-unquote to be a knight that
was cursed as a child he's not lying
about that part though the curse causes
him to look like a hedgehog during
daylight hours only turning back into a
man after midnight then changing back
into a monster at sunrise it just so
happened that he met pavetta by accident
after midnight when he was in man form
they fell in love
conceived a child in his part of the law
of surprise a long time ago he saved the
life of Queen Clancy's former husband
the king who's now died the law of
surprise says that which he had but did
not know of at the time which was his
future daughter pavetta
so Dooney has come back to claim what is
his pavetta
but he's also in love with her they want
to get married and have the child Queen
Clancy predictably isn't having any of
it because she wants to use pavetta
'he's arranged marriage to bolster her
army but Geralt has to step in to save
Dooney and beat some sense into everyone
so number one WTF Geralt claims
ciri as the child of surprise without
really knowing what he's doing you kind
of learned through the episode
he's like okay whatever you know love
surprise I'll do what you did and then
surprise surprise she finds out that
pavetta is pregnant aw crap I guess that
means that I'm gonna get a child that I
didn't expect so that's how Syrians up
becoming bound to garel through the law
of surprise in destiny they say destiny
so many times drink every time someone
on the TV show says the word destiny you
will be dead before the middle of the
season the big change they make from the
books here though is when all this stuff
happens Geralt claims the law of
surprise he saves dooney's life that's
all accurate to the books but he doesn't
actually learn that ciri exists that
pavetta had a child till way later in
the timeline there's a whole bunch other
stuff that's happening in these episodes
but because the way Netflix releases
stuff dump style all at once it's just
really hard for me to do videos for each
single episode so I will do more videos
for the season and for specific big
moments but leave all your requests in
the comments below
they've already renewed the show for
season two they'll probably just adapt
blood of elves which is the first real
novel that's when he actually starts
training ciri to become a Witcher just
like him I'll be posting more witcher
more Mandalorian and more Star Wars
videos this week so as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you should
see all the videos when I post them but
everyone click here for my Star Wars
rise of Skywalker top 20 WTF video in
Easter eggs and click here for my
Mandalorian episode 7 video thank you so
much for watching happy holidays
everyone I'll see you guys tonight